[Music]
[Applause]
Andy Cohen is back at work as the host
of a love connection at season two and
as an executive producer on the Real
Housewives of New York City's 10th
season New York expectation is this will
be the best season of Real Housewives
ever not just New York of the whole
franchise not your expectation that's
good
not even just mine that's like fan well
let me tell you something it's so good
you know it's it's all the same cast the
show ended last year so well and we just
thought we don't want to we don't want
to change a thing and I'm glad we didn't
it's interesting to see there's some you
know Bethenny and Carole's friendship
has really changed I'm not excited to
see me as LuAnn has an incredible story
arc from beginning to end she begins the
season having just split from Tom winds
up getting arrested in the middle of the
season quitting alcohol and just it's
it's incredible to see what happens
there Luann's getting out of rehab I've
been traveling to words I'm gonna say
boat trip yes
boat trip much of what has been reported
about the boat trip is completely wrong
they did have a squirrely boat trip but
there was no fire the boat didn't sink I
mean it's been grossly misrepresented
okay when you got your field notes from
that day though what was your reaction
well I had already I was in touch with
him before I got the field notes and you
know I look every day the New York
housewives field notes are the best to
read because something crazy happens
every shoe one word to describe this
season of New York coming up hilarious
and dramatic and shocking that's what we
look for
you